Skitty-boop welcome to a new video
Last week I asked you write me a poem,
that's right, Christian channel
We do poetry every Sunday now. That's right
Now I can already tell you guys have failed as
Always, I asked for poets. What do I get?
shitty memes
*YES BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE DO POODS*
Shut up, it's not funny well, it's my duty to review it
That's why I'm here to review your poems ok
I'll give you a poem right now, to show how is it is
Roses are red
violets are blue
*Loading*
Alright, let's go. Let's go. Let's review them I've seen this one ok wait. Oh, I see you changed it
It's not a poem though say nibba and nobody bats an eye, okay
Alright moving on the possibility of World War 3 PewDiePie says the n-word once
My nama Pewdiepie, and I respect women, Sweden is my city, Marzia Edgar and Maya's my life
I don't need to make new content my squad fam does that for me
Just set for me when my girlfriend's out fake Marzia's my BAE, scare PewDiePie may have got cancelled
But I still got paid
anyway
You did it. You did it, you did the poem.
"I found your future". Hey, I'll take it that looks freaking hot man.
God damn Pewdiepie is blue
Markiplier is red
Jacksepticeye is green and together. They are the Powerpuff Girls. How is that a poem?
Get-get out of this
his content is dying just as I feared. not racist ? stop lying, but look at that beard...
I Pray every day his hair is white he makes me gay. I think about him at night. He respect whamen
He'll always be lit he can't afford samon because YouTube is shit
Alright not bad not bad. Oh here. Oh, a video
What's the night before AdSense when all through the tube. Not a person was streaming not even our Pewds
The salary would come by the morning we thought in hopes that St.Google
some revenue will have brought. When out on the forums arose such a chitter
I sprang from my bed to check on my Twitter, away from the videos it flew like a flash
Tore open the website and threw out the ads, Pewds sprang to our aid to his team gave a whistle
And back came the ads like the down of a thistle
The apocalypse was over. What a hero our fellow. Happy youtubing, wait. Why are all my videos yellow?
Told wait why my old videos yellow ?actually they're not anymore, Christian Channel
It works every time Christian Channel Pewdiepie's Christian Channel
Who would have thought, family friendly ? GET OUT. Christian Channel ? *weird sounds wtf*
That's what I'm talking about, it changes everything
Hahaha, roses are red, violets are blue, The only thing I want to say is lasso users : fvck you
Use the pen tool god damn it. I mean gosh darn it
I mean Gosh darn it. You know what these are not bad so far. Good job. Also. I realized. I look a little short
Let it go, now I look taller
Here's a poem about PewDiePie a man who touched the sky all the haters will say wow, cuz he's Christian Channel now
Here's a whole new twist something you may have missed I bet you didn't know Jesus Christ is a bro.
OH SHIT!
Too bad, I'm not doing a brofist in that picture, but whatever you know I digress oh my god
This is like some ancient scroll shit. There once was a Swede
That went on to lead a squad of a fam
England their City
Despite all the worst they kept to the course and day after day
Zero deaths had occurred
Respect wamen for life
Sisterfist til we die
and dab on the haters
Squadfam is both out
Okay
Violets are blue. Roses are red. I hope slippy is not dead.
Slippy is not dead stop saying my toad is dead it looks bad for..
Slippy you're not dead right ?
There's a difference between dead and sleeping alright. I woke him up from his fellow slumber
OOOH FUCK WHY DO HE HAVE TO PEE EVERY GODDAMN TIME *That's so funny i swear Slippy is my soulmate*
Every time dude fuck
Alright, you're not dead but you're dead to me, How about that ? Think about that
On my new chair
You made me swear on a Christian channel
Roses are red violets are blue. You make Youtube better by just being you oh
No
Something nice there must be a twist. Oh my god. Thank you. That's so sweet
A poem from Ao Oni
What the heck. the past now is fleeting with all our early struggles
I came here for nostalgia all I got was puzzles
Yes
Good that was awesome. Dude, so if you don't know if you're a fake fan you didn't watch the only video. I'm just kidding
Yeah, I came for nostalgia and the game was just puzzles and he ruined all the nostalgia man
Oh day by Dave made one okay, alright. What do we get P is for Powerful, the top of the top
E is for Expectations starting to drop
W is for women we respect a lot. D is for Demonetization, which wasn't your doing
Pewds : Yes you're right // I is for Influence
To all that are viewing
E is for those Eyes that are clearly attractive
P is for the Portion of your subs that are active
I is for Intentionally causing some drama
And E is for the end of this poem, for Poppa
Sure sure sure you could have been a little nicer. Okay, that's cool. So you took my tutorial and you did my thumbnail
That's so cool. If you're an idiot you clearly haven't learned anything my god
What is this garbage? I'd have to trace enough to trace out your garbage, okay?
Disgusting. I told you I told you about contrast goodnight told him about you. What is this garbage?
I can't even see what it is. Also. Why did you add the stupid microphone there? Huh?
What does that does that add anything to the picture I think not
Hater's voice : Uhh Pewdiepie doesn't make original content
Yeah, at least I know how to make a goddamn thumbnail there you go alright
Let's look at your garbage look at mine perfect garbage perfect garbage perfect go home
You know what this might actually be true
Maybe my dad was Hagrid after all and that's why JK Rowling hates me so much it all makes sense
Can you guys tell JK? I'm a Christian Channel now, so maybe she would take me back
I would really appreciate that. roses are red violets are blue Pewdiepie stole this idea from Jack's films, too
He makes one every single day every day
How am I supposed to know? Can you guys- Seriously it's not cool Jack hasn't been replying to my texts
There's clearly something off between us
And you guys aren't helping
By implying that I'm stealing his content because you can't steal content if there's none there to begin with
"I feel confident that 2017 is gonna be a much better year." Did I actually said that ? Well..
You know what can you do.
Fucked up again, news articles everywhere ,now I'm hated ? quick better save the ad revenue
so
christian pewdiepie
activated
This is tight man. Christian- Christian Pewdiepie save ya.
That's right um, I've come back to YouTube to save it with Christian Channel if you're not a Christian channel
I urge you to join me on my quest
To save the ad revenue
I'm the Messiah and the destroyer get it. Roses are red violets are blue Wall Street Journal
Omae wa mou shindeiru *It means You're already dead, that's meme culture"
I think this is my favorite. That's awesome ,well done.
NANI?!
Elevateoheyo
Roses are red
The flowers are dead
It's very nice to meet you my name is Jeff. I'm from Ohio and so is Jake Paul
Multi-millionaire goddamn can't even get an a/c installed oranges are orange, but apples are red
I thought I could cure him by getting rid of his forehead
Summer is for swimsuits fall is for flannel have so many subscribers. They're trying to kill my channel
It's almost 2018 don't make fun of my fucking frog PewDiePie is still the most sub Channel and believe you used to sell hot dogs
Roses are red violets are blue
Not actually mad you wouldn't follow me on Twitter, but also
FVCK YOUUU
Christian Channel can't show.
Roses are read, good Christians rejoice, Swedish man draws penis with his voice
Yes
We found the queen and king of YouTube oh my god someone took a picture of us, that's so awkward
I was feel like I'm so watching (??) these scenarios, and now you know what I guess I am
It was really good. I really loved the concert though. Just say hi. You don't know don't take sneak pics, man
it's weird. roses are red violets are bigger, *misses  shot in PUBG* NO NO NOOOOO IT'S A CHRISTIAN CHANNEL NOW
Dude alright, you know what well done. I am actually not completely disappointed this time. I'm just slightly uh
You know for once for once you sort of took my challenge, and you accepted it, and you know what?
This one is for you because you know what you didn't do terrible so at least you get a little clap see good job
What do you want? Huh? What do you that's it? That's it go, GO !!!
The video is over
Just go why haven't you gone yet *cause i have to freaking sub til the end* leave a like while you're at it, then huh have you done that yeah?
What do you want you we don't want the Pollard's to take over is that what you want ?
Subscribe. Next challenge
Challenge for next week will be- Alright what is Jackfilms doing now
Food related!
That's right anything take PewDiePie take food and smash them together alright anything food related
You can submit. That's it for me for now. Love you guys so much
love you guys so much ! Squad fam